the jets debacle probably top of mind
but i think we start with some of the
positives the cleveland browns baker
mayfield
what's the biggest story when you think
about cleveland getting to nine and
three stefanski coming over and he's
right in the middle of that conversation
for coach of the year what's the biggest
story out of cleveland right now in your
eyes
to me it's kevin kevin stefanski and um
i think he's done a great job not trying
to micromanage baker mayfield he really
opened up the offense we know that they
can run the ball with their one-two
punch at running back but getting baker
mayfield to throw the ball down the
field be aggressive and not just be a
game manager and that's i i love the
fact that baker's aggressive he's
showing a lot of confidence he's into it
he's running down the field he's
cheering his guys on i think it's
awesome man and i'm not gonna sit here
and tell you that this is gonna be the
baker mayfield that we're gonna see the
next month or the year of the season but
it's just really encouraging to be able
to see him go out there and play and not
really have any limits
when he plays like this people believe
in him like teammates believe in him
he's got that energy that edge about him
and he always has had it it's just when
he's been regressing a bit on the field
the belief has lingered with it
i can't help but think how much better
he's looked since odell beckham jr has
not been on the field though he looks so
much more confident with jarvis landry
as his number one he looks more like a
leader he doesn't look like he has to
force the ball to anybody or if there's
an ego battle on the sideline it looks
like he's the man he's the leader of the
team jarvis buys totally into that i
think he believes that's what's going to
help them win and it all trickles down
from there i do want to go coach of the
year right now though if you had the
vote would you give it to stefanski or
where would you lean right now uh with
this whole debate because that's going
to be coming down the stretch these last
few weeks of the season
i tell you jack that's an awesome
question because at first before you
know i'm thinking maybe mike tomlin
because they're undefeated and but what
kevin stefanski has done with this team
and think about all the distractions
that that we heard about last year
coming out of there all the unrest and
you know the back and forth and the
coach and just everything that was going
on you don't hear any of that like kevin
stefanski he's come in and he's really
solidified that team the organization
guys are playing hard they're focused
it's it's not guys pointing fingers
blaming people in the media of course
winning helps that but it's the
leadership that kevin stefanski has uh
provided and i think right now he should
be coach of the year
i think i'm with you on that just given
the history of it for baker mayfield's
standpoint too
there has been a million quarterbacks
going there top draft pick guys that
have had all-world success in college
and everyone just goes he's going to be
the guy that's going to fix cleveland
he's going to be the guy that fixes
cleveland and one after another nobody's
been able to do it and it goes for the
coaches too i mean it's just been a
carousel of every coach you can throw
into that role and everybody has failed
except for these two
and i think it gives you an idea of how
hard it is when you saw freddie kitchens
this was a good team last year this was
a good roster last year and it didn't
work it didn't work at all so fancy
comes over and for it to work this
quickly to just snap the fingers turn
the lights on and go
this guy knows what he's doing he knew
what he was doing come before he got to
cleveland and he's showing that he is
what knows what to do and he's not only
an offensive coordinator but the boss
man as well
and it's it's a different confidence
that you see from baker mayfield before
it was a confidence that he knew that he
had confidence because of what he's
accomplished in the past
now he has confidence knowing that you
know what i can still have that success
on this level and he feels like that he
can he can play against anyone and
that's what they're going to need is
especially with their schedule come and
do they got to play baltimore the um
giants jets and pittsburgh so i i love
the fact that baker mayfield he was
aggressive in the first half he threw a
lot of yards four touchdowns and the key
jack no interceptions no one's going to
say that his passing rating is going to
be
154.6 in the future but if he can
continue not to turn the ball over
inspire his teammates continue to hustle
and be that cheerleader you talked about
jarvis landry i had an opportunity to
interview him when he was down in miami
and i tell you
he's a football player if you get a
chance to spend some time with him he
loves football he talks football he
breathes it he's a ultimate team player
he is awesome you made an excellent
point about odell beckham i think when
you do have a star receiver like odell
as a you know these guys want numbers
they want to be able to put up numbers
and if they look up and julio jones and
all these other guys devonte adams
all these catches he's looking like man
i need my catches so he gets an attitude
and you're right since odell he's he's
gone
it just seems like baker is at you know
such peace and he's just very confident
right now
it is this is this is the aaron rodgers
version of baker mayfield this is the
drew brees version he's taking easy
completions but he's also fitting them
into some really tight spots yes where
it's just like it's just an unbelievable
baker throw you're going wow he's 75 and
he's completing three quarters of his
passes with drops i mean when you go
back and watch that game there's
multiple drops where baker put it right
on a receiver and he dropped it so that
could have been even higher than where
it was and here's what i like too
he's starting to get that attitude back
about him that edge a little bit of that
humor to him the real authentic baker
mayfield i think that's what works for
him let's hear from baker after the win
yesterday
what's different about you now
as opposed to
a month ago last year whatever is it
something looks different what's
different um
whenever i'm about to do something i
think would an idiot do that and if they
would then i don't do that
and he's back and he's back having fun
with the media you know what i always
like baker man because i like that
competitiveness and you know he's just
uh he's just a little cocky little dude
and i love it i mean i don't i don't i
don't want my quarterback being timid i
want my quarterback to have confidence
and baker was tremendous once he got
outside the pocket he kept his vision
down the field like you said he put some
beautiful passes down the field right in
the receiver's hands a couple times they
dropped it but like i said before i love
the competitiveness look at him he's
having fun this is what football is
supposed to be about it's not about
losing it's about having fun and winning
ball games and they definitely have the
talent to play with anybody
it's an interesting debate because we
had this we sort of had we got into this
debate a little bit in a production
meeting recently can you be a great
quarterback in the nfl without being
somewhat cocky without having that
confidence about yourself can you think
of anyone maybe eli manning he's the
only one but i think he has that he has
that confidence underneath and he sort
of levels it out just given that he was
in the same family with cooper and with
peyton who are such big personalities
that he sort of took that back seat can
you think of a great quarterback that
didn't have that
you know edge and confidence and
cockiness about them
not at all because i mean i think of
guys that i played with like some of the
older guys that are hall of famers like
dan marino john elway joe montana steve
young all those guys those guys even if
they weren't like outwardly cocky they
had that quiet confidence and you saw it
and when i when we speak about
confidence or even cockiness what
quarterback presently comes to mind
in your in your
head what the it's not cocky you're
saying
no that's that's cocky that shows it
outwardly aaron rodgers oh
oh aaron rodgers of course no aaron
rodgers top of that list i got i think
it's it's all of them though even
mahomes mahomes is not like outwardly
cocky about it but you can just tell
when you watch him on the football field
he believes there's no better player in
the world than patrick mahomes right and
he carries himself that way and the
players around him believe it like when
you act like that and then you prove it
they believe it and that's how teams in
my opinion become great teams that's
between good teams and great teams is
the ones that truly believe that
with a minute 30 on the clock and a
couple time outs every time they're
going down the field and they're going
to win it and those are the great
quarterbacks aaron rodgers has that
attitude like i guarantee it the homes
has that attitude like i guarantee it
and those are the guys in my opinion
those are the two mvps those guys are
going back and forth in the mvp race
right now it's the arm it's the
confidence it's the cockiness it's all
the above and i don't think there's
anything bad about it sometimes the
words cocky gets misconstrued a little
bit but you gotta believe it man you're
going out there in front of the world
throwing the football around in holes
that are you know so tight sometimes
like you could barely even nobody could
fit it in there except for aaron rodgers
patrick holmes and they believe that
you know i was thinking about the
cleveland browns and i was thinking
about nick chubb and just how impressed
i am
as far as the quality of running back
that he is the vision the toughness the
power the speed the vision all those
different things and i started thinking
like i know derek henry he intimidates
people
but
i'm almost thinking that is nick chubb
better than derek henry because he can
do more
and you know derek is a big guy and he
intimidates people and he wears them
down but when i look at as far as the
quality of of running back i'm starting
to think that nick chubb might be the
best running back in the nfl
i think he's right up there he's up
there with one two three he's in those
in that spot for sure defensively too
maybe this browns defense is getting
slept on a little bit because because
baker and the success that he's having
but miles garrett sheldon richardson
there's some stars starting to develop
and in the secondary too who do you like
most on this browns d
i like i just i like the way they play
together it's not like guys are trying
to outdo one another or or trying to
beat the headlines miles guaranteed he's
unbelievable but what i like is the way
their safeties and their secondary and
their linebackers they did an excellent
job of tackling big derrick henry in the
open field they came up they hit his
legs they wrapped him they brought him
down and you didn't see all those missed
tackles like you saw when they played
against the indianapolis colts
let's spin it to the new york giants the
giants go to seattle and just like
everybody was thinking knock off the
seahawks it makes absolutely no sense
they're playing with colt mccoy as a
backup quarterback i feel like most
casual football fans are like wait
colt mccoy is still in the nfl yeah he
is he's still in the nfl plays for the
giants backup quarterback he just played
okay it wasn't like he came in there and
lit the seahawks on fire they had no
receiver above 35 receiving yards but
they they ran the ball all over the
seahawks defense you know and really
gotten russell wilson's face i i've
rarely do you see russell wilson look
this uncomfortable escaping and
scrambling they were sacked him five
times and a lot of them were deep sacks
how did they go in there and pull this
off over seattle
well you think about joe judge of course
coming from the belichick era and just a
lot of discipline rushes and just
getting after them they they just played
physical they got after leonard
leonard williams two and a half sacks he
was outstanding i love what uh blake
martinez did he's all over the field
sideline from sideline making tackles
jabril peppers has made some plays
shown some great leadership and the
thing about the giants is they have the
front four where they don't have to
blitz so if you don't have the blitz to
create pressure now you can keep your
safeties back you can protect your
corners and now you can react and these
guys are just flying around playing
great communication in terms of um
defense and they're just playing and
having fun and joe judge has those guys
disciplined i like what i see from him
and for russell wilson this was just one
of those off kind of games he fumbled a
snap that they ended up losing through
an interception missed some open throws
even at times dk metcalf and russell
looked like they weren't on the same
page which is a really rare thing to see
and then towards the end of the game he
threw one directly to a giants defender
that was dropped let's hear from russell
wilson on what went wrong yesterday
i think the reality of this story was
we weren't able to capitalize on
opportunities you know
you know i always talk about game
altering plays you know we didn't have
those plays unfortunately today
um like we feel like we've had you know
for the most part all season you know
we've done a great job of those and
those just didn't show up as much today
you know unfortunately and they stopped
us on some key situations you know
situational football they stopped us so
you know and then they score you know
right afterwards so i think that's where
it was
when i watch russ have a bad game it
seems to me like he just holds the
football forever when it doesn't go
right for seattle he's just holding that
thing and he runs left and he runs right
and the giants were so patient with the
way that they passed rushed him it's
like it was like we're not trying to get
him back where he is standing right now
we're trying to get him as soon as he
decides he wants to run it's like they
were just so patient holding those
tackles okay wait wait wait now's our
moment and they were just waiting right
there in that full container they got
him time after time
russ is a great player most great
players want to you know they feel like
if they can hold on to the ball they can
make the play and that's you hit it
right on the head that's what he's doing
he's holding on to the ball because
and and i think he's buying into that
whole rust let rust cook and everything
because when he drops back there are
guys open in this short zone there are
guys open but he doesn't want to pass to
them he wants the big play and they're
not getting a big play you know the
longest play was like 28 yards and that
was to a running back so it to me it
feels weird to say this but it seems
like seattle is still trying to find
their identity and russell russell
wilson is a great player but at the end
of the day if you're holding on to the
ball the way these defenses are playing
with their speed and athleticism all the
defensive ends and things like that you
can't hold on to the ball like that
especially going into these winter
months when the weather starts to change
you see rain sleet snow cold all those
different factors that um really affect
the game
it's a good point this is when they're
gonna miss the run game that they had
had so many years in the past these last
few years it's when they're gonna really
miss establishing that and then you know
you mentioned let russ cook they let
russ cook in the second half when they
needed it when they need him in those
moments and he would go do it but now
he's become the main chunk of the pie
with regard to this offense and the
running game has sort of disappeared uh
speaking of the run game wayne goldman
jr for the giants remember him back from
clemson the great clemson running back
he had some monster years at clemson he
used to score like a million touchdowns
in a season he re-emerges with the
giants and he went off yesterday he
really did
man i was so pumped for this young man
because when you see him run
he runs like almost like ricky waters i
don't maybe that's a little before your
day but ricky waters used to run with a
lot of energy high knees running people
over getting up throwing the ball down
celebrating with his teammates he runs
with a lot of positive energy so i love
to see wayne goldman people's like man
why are you talking about the giants
they beat you in a super bowl man you
got to give respect and love where it's
due they deserve it now my biggest
question with the giants before they
were just kind of you know just
teetering along now they're getting a
lot of tension now we're starting to
talk about them how will they respond
will they continue to grind and put on
their blinders or are they going to
start feeling good about themselves and
start you know reading all the headlines
we will find out we will truly find out
about that one
speaking of headlines the new york jets
at the end of the game yesterday greg
williams they go cover zero all-out
blitz in a basically a hail mary
situation
and it's it's one of the most peculiar
play calls that i've seen in this
lifetime it totally burns them they lose
the game it's wide open really back to
back plays at the end of that game where
they had wide open receivers running
down the middle of the field car misses
the first one the second one
bangs it for a touchdown
tell you what that play call that
situation what's your take
i i i tell you that like from this
standpoint i played on a team that went
one in 15
and we were owen 12. i think this was
was it 2000 i think we were on 12 and we
played against the kansas city chiefs
ironically
and we won that game and we celebrated
because we didn't want to go down as
that team oh and 16. we celebrated like
we won the super bowl and to me i look
at adam gase you're the head coach and i
was yes i was raised partly with bill
belichick and as the head coach the head
coach has final say over every single
call
and i even asked coach dungey i said are
you listening to the defensive call in a
critical moment like that he says well
if i'm not i do one thing i'm going to
call time out bring everybody together
communicate with the defensive
coordinator and figure out what we're
going to do and if i would have known
that he would have called it all out
blitz maybe i would have checked like
this is what teams practice every single
week you practice this especially with
the patriots you're gonna practice this
almost every day situational football
you're gonna practice it on friday the
hail mary you're gonna practice it last
play on saturday you're gonna walk
through these things so it's not new to
you it's not foreign to you and for a
head coach not to know what coverage
they're going to be in he deserves to be
fired because he's crappy
greg williams defensive coordinator he
deserved to be fired like i said last
night and if i'm trevor lawrence why the
heck would i want to go to a franchise
with adam gase why would i want to do
something like that i if i'm trevor
lawrence i'm sitting back saying you
know what if the jets draft me i'm not
going i'm sitting out of here
if adam gates is the head that's a whole
another
that's a whole nother conversation i
would say first and foremost if adam
gase is still the head coach
that's that's a whole can of worms right
there that's that would be shocking to
me shocking to me now trevor lawrence
not coming out this year that would not
be shocking to me whatsoever clemson in
general is different that place keeps
assistant coaches for decades great
assistant coaches that have head
coaching opportunities they stick around
dabo sweeney creates a culture down
there that people want to be a part of
think about travis etn he could have
came out this year he would have been a
high draft pick all of those things yes
he chooses to go i mean think about the
shelf life for running backs it's only
you know four or five years that these
nfl teams really are willing to pay and
put resources into it and then they're
redrafting or going younger or going
cheaper or going to free agency and he
wanted to go back to clemson and chase
another championship that gives you some
idea what the culture is and i think
trevor lawrence is a different cat i
think this is an andrew luck kind of guy
and i i would not be surprised
whatsoever if he decides i don't want to
be in new york yet
and to me you know it just seemed like
when he made that call because i i
really could not believe he made that
call like i'm like you you have to be
joking like you're you're showing the
world that you want to lose you you
don't want to win like when the
quarterback sees those linebackers and
and creeping up
he knows what's coming and even carr
said i was surprised how could they
blitz in a situation like that
like even if you rush three jack and you
drop eight guys and you get eight guys
all you do is protect the sideline you
protect the end zone if they catch the
ball inbounds and you make the tackle
the game is over but it seemed like they
were trying to lose for that number one
pick and i cannot respect that i cannot
respect guys this is professional
football you get paid a lot of money to
keep the opposing guy from getting in
the end zone and to me this was sick
this was disgusting and if i was the
owner of the jets i would have fired
adam gates i would have fired um defense
coordinator greg williams i would get
rid of both of those guys
well the thing with greg williams is
this is who greg williams has been his
whole career i mean he's out of his mind
the guy loves to bring you know his
favorite play is the engage eight if you
any any madden players out there it's
just what he loves to do he loves to hit
quarterbacks he loves to get in their
face with pressure that's just is what
he does and it late game situation it
doesn't matter he is just known as the
blitzer lamar jackson though you're
gonna do a double take when i say lamar
jackson but that was the cornerback
that's covering at that very last play
it's a hail mary situation all you got
to do is get deep and get deep in a
hurry and he bites on the double move he
bit on it like what are you doing biting
on the double move and running towards
the sideline it was just a layup that's
way too easy for carr in the raiders but
jack what you're describing jack is bad
coaching even technique the mindset like
you go over these plays and even as a
safety if i'm marcus may i'm saying look
guys we're staying deep and if something
were to happen like that i'm looking at
my defensive coordinator i said blitz oh
we can't blitz here this is this is the
last play of the game we cannot blitz
here coach
can i get a timeout let's talk about
this see me as a captain i would have
went over there and talked to my head
coach my defensive coordinator said are
you sure this is what you want to do and
if even if he were to say yes this is
what i want to do i would have told my
corners don't fall for any double moves
they have to score if they want to win
this game sit back 20 25 yards but don't
go for the double move but that's
coaching
lack of leadership in the secondary
think about if jamal adams was there
think about jamal adams and that strong
personality there's no way he would have
let that ride he was like nah we're not
caught we're not we're not doing this
nope nope check two two two he would
have checked went into a different but
that's what you're missing when you
don't have that leadership on the
defense
i bet you maul's awful happy he's not
there right now if i had to guess a man
he's
not a part of that yeah he's probably
very happy that he's not there but yeah
just just a very strange finish that
game and you're thinking the jets are
finally gonna pull one off but this is
this is getting ugly for the raiders now
too like we have seen some of the worst
versions worst versions of the raiders
these last handful of weeks are what's
what's your take on where they're going
are the raiders are the raiders real or
the raiders not at times they look like
they can hang with the chiefs and you go
oh this is this is one of the real
rising emerging teams in the nfl and
they look like they can't beat the jets
or they get stomped out and shut out and
you can't figure out where in between
this team might fall
well i mean everybody has injuries you
know obviously jonathan abram and josh
jacobs they they miss the offensive line
seems like they're tired it just seems
like the raiders are tired you think
about everything that they put into
beating kansas city early in the year
the second game that they played against
kansas city it just seems like maybe
coach needs to kind of let you know
ease up on practice or something because
they don't look fresh they don't look
excited to play football darren waller
had a heck of a
game he had 200 yards receiving he was
all over the place and finally they get
him back involved with no josh jacobs
but they have a lot of young players and
a lot of times young players in a long
nfl season and it's real they hit that
rookie wall and whether it's a rookie
first year or second year especially
with everything that's going on with
this covet and everything that you know
you know people have to go through this
year you know you get tired man you wear
down mentally and that's what it seems
like the raiders are doing
it's an interesting point and gruden's
really an old school old school style of
coach in a new school style of football
so i would guess that that winding you
know that grinding on the players
throughout the course of the season is
very real
sean payton he may be may classify as a
bit of an old school style coach as well
he is a new school style quarterback
right now though taysom hill has stepped
in and really he hid very well
throughout the course of the season
leading up to taste him taking over as a
starter the fact that he could throw the
ball i mean even when they would bring
him into the game it was a straight
almost like a wildcat style of offense
even if they had an open receiver taysom
wasn't throwing the ball over about two
or three weeks though he's starting to
look like drew brees back there from the
pocket he is hitting everybody all over
the field getting it done there and then
when he takes off and runs he looks like
this top shelf of athletes playing the
quarterback position in the nfl right
now man man jack you just summed it up
man and i tell you man even if drew
brees comes back if i'm a defense i'm
almost looking relieved like okay okay
drew we don't have to worry about
hitting taysom we don't have to worry
about the play breaking down
off-schedule plays and him making plays
so to me
drew is the better quarterback but
taysom is the more dangerous weapon like
just think about all the factors from a
defensive standpoint oh okay when they
go on this m when they go on this set we
have to worry about this the
quarterbacks need the design quarterback
run so as a defense your preparation is
going to lead you to have to worry about
everything whether it's rpos
play action pass down the field
quarterback design keeps all those
different things as a defense you have
to worry about with drew you worry about
his experience you worry about his his
accuracy you worry about just the
maturity and him seeing the entire field
but i tell you taysom has been wonderful
jack and this is my last point with
taysom
think about how difficult it is for a
guy like him to play four or five
different positions whether it's tight
in
full back
wide receiver on the special teams doing
all the different things that he does
and then he comes in and he has to lead
a team as a quarterback not as a option
quarterback but as a drop back
quarterback like that's to me that's one
of the most amazing things i've seen
this year like this is on the highest
level this is a guy that's playing four
or five positions on the highest level
that you can play football 000 nfl
players roughly and he's playing four or
five positions you tell me any other guy
that can do that national football
league taysom hill is special
there's nobody there's nobody that can
do that i don't it's not even specific
to this time frame i can't remember in
the last 10 15 years anybody that's been
able to do that you'd correct me if i'm
wrong there i mean this is one of the
most unique football players in the
history of the game i've ever seen back
then you can now do it from the pocket i
mean so drew brees i'm with you the
experience all those things the accuracy
but that arm does not have the same
rocket fuel that it once did and so
you'll see drew brees have a receiver
about 25 yards down the field that's
open and he's just dinking and dunking
to camaro at all times when you watched
that game yesterday camaro is wide open
that little dink and dunk it is wide
open just like it's always been with
breeze but taysom doesn't care he's
stepping into a throw and he's putting
it 25 yards down the field on a p for a
first down it's a different element of
this offense that they have been lacking
to start this year so i want to make
sure i'm hearing you right a little bit
here rodney are you saying that when
breeze comes back healthy is there a
decision to be made for the home stretch
i know it's no i'm not saying that
because i already know where sean payton
stands in this i mean he and drew brees
have a relationship and he he's gonna
give drew brees this last and final shot
no doubt about it if he's healthy um but
what i'm saying is
as a defensive player there are
strengths and there's weaknesses to both
of these guys and i just see more
probably more weakness in terms of you
know just making big plays with drew
brees you talked about it like defenses
they're giving drew brees that deep
throat daring him to throw that ball
down deep because now they're saying
okay we're gonna just focus on camaro
come up and make the tackle whereas
taysom hill
they're like okay we're gonna give up
the little dump offs and we're gonna
make sure that we stay disciplined on
the back end of the defense because we
know that this kid can throw the ball 60
yards down the field so anytime you play
against one or the other you have to
adjust your thinking as far as how you
want to play those guys
and injuries have really made this team
this saints team a lot better because
when they lost michael thomas traequan
smith had to step up and be the number
one wide receiver and slowly but surely
he proved that he is a good wide
receiver in the nfl too now michael
thomas comes back he's a beast we all
know what michael thomas is and now he's
playing like that has a little chemistry
already going with taysom hill too
traequan smith is a great number two
receiver emmanuel sanders is the number
three receiver i mean come on now he was
awesome for san francisco down the home
stretch he's the number three receiver
jared cook tight end very underrated guy
camara coming out of the backfield and
now you got to think about brees if he's
the ace like you're saying taysom hill
comes into the game and you can't treat
him like a wildcat quarterback anymore
because he can throw the ball i mean
this is going to be a lot to worry about
trying to stop the new orleans saints
and it's all going to be new and fresh
come playoff time that's going to be a
lot to think about
yeah and you know what and guess what
sean payton's going to do he's going to
continue to incorporate taysom hill
allow him to come in and make plays
because he knows how it affects a
defense i mean look at the guy he's a
smart kid
you know no interceptions rush yards 83
yards rushing so you add him on equation
as far as latavius murray and alvin
kamara
they're having a lot of success running
the football so now you're saying okay
we got to load up the bots stop taste
them stop these guys and now you have
one-on-one opportunities and that's
exactly what you want with michael
thomas you want one-on-one opportunities
and who's going to stop them i mean this
guy has 100 plus catches every year
nobody's going to stop he's too physical
he plays angry does all those things and
then you have to taste him throwing the
ball and taysom takes off and runs and
he's he's like he's built like a
fullback he runs like uh you know runs
like a receiver and he throws like a
quarterback he's like the most you just
can't wrap your head around let's hear
from taysom hill this man's undefeated
right now as a starting quarterback for
the new orleans states here he was after
another win
i don't care as much as um
you know people might think about
statistics and you know all this stuff i
care about winning football games i know
there's been a lot of conversations
about
and getting your first touchdown
completion um but as long as we're
winning football games
i'm happy so
um i was certainly happy about it
because i knew it was going to help us
win
and i was happy for trey quan and he ran
a great route and
coach that was a late ad in the week and
um
you know it's one of those things that
makes coach payton coach peyton
jack how could you not like that guy
just the humility all the success that
he's having and he says i don't care
about all that all i care about is
winning and you're sean payton and you
know that drew brees this year maybe
next year whenever he decides to walk
away you know that you have this young
man who's playing extremely well in your
offense but you know he's this is the
type of leader this is the type of
personality that you have at the court
starting quarterback position so those
guys are looking at him like
we'll run through a brick wall because
they see how tough he is they see how
unselfish he is they see how he
sacrifices so much and he's all about
the team so this is one of my favorite
players in the national football league
him jamal um adams aaron donald i love i
just love the personality of these guys
because it's more about the team and
less about themselves
amen let's move from one backup
quarterback having success to another
this may be we may be talking about two
new starting quarterbacks at this point
let's get to jalen hurts hertz comes in
for wince and i want to start with the
sound we have we have wince we have doug
peterson the head coach on why they
benched wince won't went into that
decision then ultimately jalen hurts
let's hear from them first then we'll
discuss
you know at the time um i just felt like
where we were as an offense we needed a
spark you know we needed we needed uh
um something to uh kind of kind of go
our way and and um so i decided to uh
you know put jalen in the game i'm not
the type to to worry about and look over
my shoulder or any of those things you
know i think um at the end of the day
i can play better we can as a team and
as an offense especially play better
and you know there's always going to be
different things going on um in the
building or different you know chatter
and all that stuff that's part of part
of this business and you know that's
what you know i think i've said it a
couple times it's what i signed up for
um the scrutiny you know the challenges
the adversity all of it um i gotta
handle it all um the good bad and the
ugly who's going to start a quarterback
for you against the saints
you know um
you know you guys are listening you got
to get let me get through this game you
know um you just heard me say we needed
a we needed a spark in this game to
to try to get some things going you know
there's uh i've got to get through
injuries i got to get through the tape
but you know there's a lot of
a lot of things that i'm gonna i'm gonna
consider
um and and evaluate before um
you know before anything's uh decided
so so basically doug peter is saying you
know i'm gonna go upstairs i'm gonna
have some conversations with the
ownership and the general manager and
we're gonna figure out who's gonna be
the starting quarterback but to me as a
coach i wouldn't hesitate to put jalen
hurts he looked more poised he looked
more confident he looked more athletic
and he just was younger he's just fresh
and just like i mean this guy's he had
an accomplished college career he's gone
through some adversity so you know he's
mentally tough he's always been a humble
kid
jack
i don't know about you bro but i would
not
hesitate to put jalen hurts in and i'm
not saying he's going to go out there
and throw for 300 and some yards but
he's going to provide you with that
spark and now you get a chance to see
you know what
what what is my second round pick doing
like what are the things that we can do
with him and build around him you you
wouldn't have drafted him so high if you
didn't believe in him so give him my
opportunity and and doug peterson has to
go in there as the head coach and demand
that respect and say you know what i'm a
head coach i feel like this guy gives us
the best opportunity to play and i
thought he made some some nice passes
yesterday
i agree with you and it wasn't like
wince was awful he didn't didn't throw
four interceptions or do something like
that he just didn't do anything good
he's just like just so bland six of 15
the eagles paid him way before they had
to they could have waited a couple more
years and seen if if it was real if it
was real what they had with carson wentz
i mean it was ultimately foals that
carried him home in that super bowl run
and i understand wentz played really
well to get him to that position
six of 15 79 yards is what he had no
picks
so
i think you i think you ride the hot
hand here and i see a lot of
similarities between this situation and
the taysom hill situation because when
when hertz was picked a lot of people
said oh he's a runner and they're going
to bring him in and they'll do wildcat
type stuff in both of those quarterbacks
hertz and taysom hill have proven
quickly that that's not what they are
when they've gotten their chance to step
in and be a pocket pastor they've both
proven that no no they can throw two and
that's what the nfl is now who can run
and who can throw two it's the combo
it's not one or the other it's the combo
and both those guys are showing signs of
having the combo and i think you got to
taper the expectations a little bit you
know we've seen backup quarterbacks come
in it's a spark and then it's harder
when they start and their game plan for
and all those things so taper the
expectations but wince hasn't showed you
enough to go we got to double down on
what he's doing so i'm with you i think
you ride the hot hand until it's not hot
anymore
bro i look at carson wentz and i see and
everybody i mean it's noted he holds on
to the ball too long and all those
different things but a lot of times he's
just throwing the ball he just and
throws it and and he's throwing it and
he's praying like
and it's just bad it's like okay where
is he throwing the ball to and like this
is the guy you gave a hundred and
something million guaranteed to
but when i look at jalen hurts he came
in and he gave him it just the freshness
the speed the you know he saw the pocket
break down he scrambled to the left he
scrambled to the right he made a couple
yards here and there i just think that
they need to give him opportunity and i
say this every single week when i talk
about jalen hurts not as an option
quarterback give him normal plays and
then in the off season you continue to
go out there you get some um you drafted
some young guys you get them some
weapons and you continue to build and
work on that offensive line but here and
now this is an opportunity for you to
even if jalen hurts doesn't play great
you get a chance to see how he handles
adversity and to me that's that's one of
the most important things when you're
trying to evaluate players
he had two beautiful throws in that game
i'm thinking about that deep one down
the left sideline and then again when
he's scrambling to the right he's on the
move and puts one right in the end zone
perfectly placed uh speaking of
perfectly placed aaron rodgers he seems
to me right now like he is just sick of
everything he's sick of jordan love he's
sick of the scrutiny he's sick of
sharing commercials with patrick mahomes
he's sick of people acting like patrick
mahomes invented the no-look pass he's
sick of all of it he just looks angry he
looks so mad to me and it's translating
into just perfect game after perfect
game after perfect game he's not making
mistakes like
when i say not making mistakes not about
interceptions he's not throwing in
completions he's just like everything he
does he hits it's crazy what he's doing
right now and all of a sudden this mvp
race is going from mahomes to rogers and
it's starting to level out a little bit
especially
a little bit last night on sunday night
football let's see you rod
yeah aaron rodgers has been great and
devonte adams he's having a heck of a
year but you know what i what i said a
couple weeks ago and even last week is
this offense you know aaron jones needs
to be the focal point of this offense
and you saw that that basically the
game-winning run i mean that was huge
for him and to be able to just flip the
ball out there to devonta adams and know
that he's gonna use his size his
strength against the smaller defensive
back
man those are just little
almost like little catching runs and you
know he he's gonna get five to seven
yards every time he does it but
yeah aaron rodgers
he's confident he's playing on a
different level right now but he's he's
motivated because he wants to prove to
all the haters that he can still play
and all his talk like you just talked
about patrick mahomes is patrick my
homes like he's saying look patrick
mahomes was in high school when i was
doing what i was doing he was in grade
school when i was winning a super bowl
so don't forget about aaron rodgers but
yeah i i agree with you he's right there
in mvp race
that's right and mahomes is all of a
sudden starting to get all those same
compliments and conversations that
rogers used to get got his whole career
and we we used to talk about rogers like
that it was like he was the wonder child
alva holmes is the wonder child you know
what i'm saying there's been a little
changing of the tides there and i think
he wants to re-establish that i also
think quarterbacks of that caliber when
they get to this point in their career
they start thinking man it's been a long
time since i've won a championship yeah
a long time since i brought a super bowl
back here and he wants to go out with
one more uh and and this might be the
year this might be the year they make a
deep deep push into the playoffs maybe
make it to a super bowl
go ahead
the only thing i would say offensively i
believe that they can play with anyone
you know offensively i don't worry about
aaron rodgers like we talked about drew
brees the same thing applies with him
but a stronger arm
great vision
and the ability to run and escape
my question is that defense are you sold
on that defense because i'm not i'm not
sold on that defense i think they're
still soft up front i think they get
inconsistent pre um pressure um preston
williams he's
up and down zadarius well preston smith
he's up and downs and darius smith he's
their guy but preston smith he's not
playing on the same level that he played
on last year so i'm just
i'm just a little hesitant when it comes
to their defense right now
i i agree and preston smith though had a
big game on sunday night football
against the bears a week ago and he had
been you know i think he's had some
inconsistencies with effort and practice
and those things and it has been a point
of emphasis from the coaching staff i'll
put it that way
and he's been responding to that now how
responsibly be down the home stretch
it's it's a really good point that
probably is a deciding factor of how far
this team can go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports